>> Susan Reyburn: Okay
are we ready to roll?
All right.
Hello and thank you
all for coming.
I'm Susan Reyburn, Curator
of Baseball Americana,
an exhibition currently running
here in the Jefferson Building
and continuing through
July of 2019.
If you haven't had
a chance to check it
out yet, I hope you will soon.
Perhaps even this afternoon
after you've gotten your new
Tinker to Evers to Chance book,
had it signed by the
author and it's available
for purchase behind you
in the entryway there.
So today as we close
out our 3-part series
on new baseball publications
and prepare
to watch the Los Angeles Dodgers
win their third World Series,
win their first World
Series in 30 years,
the library is delighted
to have with us David Rapp,
author of Tinker to Evers
to Chance: The Chicago Cubs
and the Dawn of Modern America.
David spent more than 20 years
at Congressional
Quarterly serving as editor
and senior vice president.
He's a former board member of
the National Press Foundation
and he mastered his craft
as a hard-boiled newspaper
beat reporter in Memphis,
Cincinnati and Pittsburgh.
As the book's title
suggests, there's more here
than the makings of a story
double play trio made immortal
in 1910 through the
poetic musings
of New York newspaper
columnist Franklin Pierce Adams.
In addition to seeing what
made the threesome tick
and the dynamics of the Cubs
early 20th Century dynasty,
the book illumines for us the
City of Chicago in the years
after it grabbed the
world's attention as host
of the World Columbian
Exposition.
This is a fascinating read
whether you are a baseball fan
who likes history on the
side or a history buff
who likes a large
helping of baseball.
After the talk there will
be time for questions.
So ladies and gentlemen,
David Rapp.
[ Applause ]
>> David Rapp: Thank you.
I've lost the, let's
try this again here.
That'll work.
These are the saddest
of possible words,
Tinker to Evers to Chance.
A trio of bear cubs
and freer than birds,
Tinker and Evers and Chance.
Ruthlessly pricking our gonfalon
bubble making a giant hit
into a double.
Words that are heavy
with nothing but trouble.
Tinker to Evers to Chance.
So that's the way most of us
know about these three guys is
through this poem that Susan
mentioned written in 1910
by a newspaper columnist in
New York, who actually is
from Chicago and was
a lifelong Cubs fan.
And that's also obviously
the top,
the reason I wrote
the book was to find
out a little bit
more about them.
As Susan said, I'm a journalist
by training and profession.
I'm not, I'm going to
have to back off here.
I worked at Congressional Corley
and Roll Call [phonetic]
for 30 years.
I started out as a sports
writer for my hometown newspaper
in Evansville, Indiana, and
went on and have been trying
to cover sports ever since.
I got sidetracked into
politics for about 40 years
and I tell you this
is a lot more fun,
but I've also been
a Chicago Cubs fan
since I was 10 years old.
My dad got his PhD in
University of Wisconsin
over the course of 13 summers.
So I took the family up
there every year and we lived
across the hall the
first year from a lawyer,
law student from Chicago,
who brainwashed me right then
and told me I needed
to be rooting
for Ernie Banks not Mickey
Mantle or any of the things
that all the other kids were.
Little did I realize that
my passion and loyalty
of the Cubs would never
be requited through most
of my lifetime until
just 2 years ago,
but that's what got me into
this topic to begin with.
These 3 guys, Joe Tinker, Johnny
Evers or Evers as they say it
up in Troy, New York, where
he's from, and Frank Chance
where the shortstop,
second baseman
and first baseman player/manager
of the Chicago Cubs from 1903
to 1912 was there
period of time.
They're immortalized by Frank
Adams, Franklin P. Adams,
who was a member of
the, a charter member
of the Algonquin Roundtable,
which included people
like Robert Benchley
and Dorothy Parker,
but at the time 1910 he was
just a, wrote a humor column
for the New York Evening
Standard and included a lot
of poetry and things like
that including his own,
and the story goes that he had
finished up his column one day
and was on his way up to catch
a ballgame in the Polo Grounds
where the American League
Highlanders were playing.
And he got a call from the
composing room just as he was
about to leave saying his
column was 8 lines short.
So he had to come up with
8 lines and there was
on his desk a newspaper from
about the game the day before
in Chicago between the Cubs
and the Giants and deep down,
the Cubs had won the
game 4 to 2 with the help
of a rally killing play
in the 7th inning and deep
down the box score he saw
it said double play Tinker
to Evers to Chance.
And so that led to this little
piece of doggerel he produced,
which turned out to be probably
the second most famous poem
about baseball after Casey
and the Bat, Casey at the Bat.
And caused a sensation, a
viral media sensation of 1910.
The newspapers would reprint
it all over the country
and then sports editors would
write their own versions of it
from there and then he'd
reprint those and it went
on all summer long, but
became quite a sensation.
A couple things about it you
may know it as baseball lexicon.
This is actually a scan
of the original version
from the Evening
Standard in 1910.
A librarian friend of mine,
Jack Bales down at Mary
Washington University,
found for us.
Adams renamed it
Baseball Lexicon shortly
after it came out.
And then I'm sure
you're wondering
about this phrase,
our gonfalon bubble.
Anybody know what a gonfalon is?
It's a, a banner,
medieval Italian banner
or pennant especially one with
streamers hung from a cross bar
as you're going into battle.
And so if you look at that
ruthlessly pricking our gonfalon
bubble means our pennant
fever essentially.
So these are the 3 guys, Tinker,
Evers and Chance and I want
to talk a little bit about them
but also what I think is
a marvelous way of looking
at baseball at the time
and how baseball became our
national pastime.
For most of the time up until
they played it was the phrase
used most often for baseball
was the national game
and that was a product of
its history and it's kind
of way it evolved
from different games.
It was a Massachusetts
game, a New York game
and was pretty much
during the Civil War
that the rules coalesced
around one game.
So somebody from Troy, New York,
like Johnny Evers or Kansas City
like Joe Tinker or Fresno,
California, like Frank Chance,
could all play the same
game if one showed up
and they'd be playing the same
game 9 innings, 9 men to a side,
4 balls, 3 strikes, you know,
all the rules we know today
but what happened in
this first [inaudible]
of the 20th Century was
that baseball transformed
into something completely
different
and that's what I'll talk
a little bit about today.
So first of all let
me talk a little bit
about Joe Tinker,
the short stop.
As I said, he's from
Kansas City.
Actually he was born
in Muscotah, Kansas,
Atchison County, just west of
Kansas City, to an unwed mother.
He was actually one
of a, a pair of twins
but his twin sister died
or who knows what
happened very early on.
He didn't have any
memory of her.
It was some talk that he
had an Italian father.
You can kind of tell from
his looks he has that kind
of swarthy Mediterranean
good looking,
he's actually the most
popular player of the 3.
He was a real crowd pleaser in
his day and he ended up going
on into vaudeville as
a vaudevillian actor
in uniform during
his playing days.
So he made a lot of
money in the winters,
in the off season [inaudible].
Anyway his mother moved
to Kansas City was essentially
shunned out of Muscotah,
moved to Kansas City when he
was 3 or 4 years old and hooked
up with an itinerant butcher and
short-order cook named Tinker.
And they lived in Kansas
City through this childhood.
Johnny Evers or Evers as I
said Evers himself said it's
pronounced Evers in Troy
but everyone else
pronounces it Evers.
So you can do it either way
as far as he was concerned.
Specifically he's
from south Troy,
which was the Irish/American
enclave of Troy
and his nickname
was the human crab.
For one reason because he
played second base side to side
like a crab moving
sideways but also
because as one reporter
says he's just a jangled
up bundle of nerves.
Always barking at the umpire,
constantly haranguing anybody
on the other team or the umpire.
Frank Chance, who played next
to him at first base, once said,
told Tinker he says I wish
I played in the outfield
so I wouldn't have to listen
to Evers all day long.
But he also had an
amazing baseball IQ
and became famous for it.
He went to bed with the
rule book every night
and so he was a spindly little
kid, you know, he was 5 feet 5,
120 pounds or something
when he started playing.
Very different from Frank
Chance who was a big,
one of the biggest players of
his day at 6 feet, 190 pounds.
Again, he's from
Fresno, California.
He was an amateur boxer.
When he was growing
up, he played football,
he was a mountaineer,
anything he could do in terms
of proving his physical
prowess he was willing to do.
His nickname out in
California was Husk for tough
as a corn husk, but Chicago
sports writers eventually would
refer to him as the
perilous leader
because he was a man
totally in charge.
So what we've got here is
kind of a map of America
in these 3 guys from
Troy in Upstate New York
to Kansas City to Fresno.
As you can see, this is a
demographic map from 1890.
The country kind of ends around
Kansas City and then picks
up again on the West
Coast at that time.
So America was essentially
a composite
of very distinct
regional cultures and each
of these men reflected that
especially when they came
to Chicago together in 1903.
Evers was a product of a
classic Irish stem family.
This is a family photo.
He's the young boy in the middle
in the back row he was about 14.
His father was an iron monger.
His grandfather was an
immigrant came across in 1840s
as a penniless immigrant
from Ireland.
John Evers, Sr got a job
at the iron works in Troy.
Troy was probably the biggest
iron center of the country
in the middle of
the 19th Century.
And eventually got hooked
up with the Democratic
political machine.
Became quite a successful
political operative.
His father was actually the,
became president and chairman
of the school board
even though he sent all
of his kids to parochial
schools.
Kansas City at the time was a
boom town on the west thanks
to railroads and the stockyards
that they had and
things like that.
In fact, it was such a boom town
it was considered too crowded
for its own good.
Families wouldn't move there
because there was just no space
to run around and
we'll talk a little bit
about that in a minute too.
And then Frank Chance
each of his parents came
across to California on the
Oregon Trail as children.
The young boy there in the
middle is about the age
of William Chance
when he came across
and as this shows they
came across on foot.
It was 2000 miles.
Those wagons weren't for people.
The wagons was for their stuff.
And it was an obviously arduous
ordeal through mountains,
desert and snow storms
in the upper mountains.
Dennis Chance, Frank's
grandfather, was part of a party
that came over in one of the
first 1846 and they were just
about a week or two
ahead of the Donner Party
as they crossed the
Sierra Nevadas.
So, it was, it was essentially
the defining moment of that,
not just that family but
that state and the culture
that was developing
out in California
through the second
half of the century.
So baseball as I said was
still a formative sport.
There was many different
games and rules.
The Civil War helped
foster this national game.
This is a picture of a prisoner
of war camp in North Carolina
where union soldiers
were playing baseball.
Then they all came
back home after the war
and started developing the game
pretty much as we know it today.
the 1880s is when professional
baseball really took off.
The National League
was founded in 1876.
The 1880s were a free-wheeling,
fun for fun sake kind
of time for baseball.
It was personified by this
guy Mike King Kelly who played
for the Chicago White Stockings
and then eventually for Boston.
It was free spirited,
lots of showmanship,
lots of gamesmanship,
but it was all in fun
and everybody sort
of took it that way.
This is a classic
painting that hung on a lot
of barroom walls called
Slide, Kelly, Slide.
He was the Babe Ruth of his day.
In fact, some people said he
was more popular in his day
than Babe Ruth was in his.
Hard for us to believe
but this was a witness
who saw both men play.
In the meantime,
baseball was kind
of developing also
regional interests.
This is a picture of
the old Troy Haymakers.
Troy was just a baseball mad
town and all the Evers, brothers
and uncles and cousins everybody
played baseball in Troy.
And Kansas City as I said was
very crowded, overcrowded place,
but the city fathers realized
that and remarkably started one
of the first of the City
Beautiful Movements that came
across the United States
and hired a protege
of Frederick Long Olmsted to
come and design a whole system
of parks and boulevards that
still exist in the city today.
So this is where Joe Tinker
grew up playing baseball was
in these kind of parks.
There was also a center for an
organization called the Society
of Christian Endeavor.
It was a youth Christian
organization, ecumenical.
It was developed to
try to get boys back
into the church frankly and
one of the things that emerged
out of that was because kind
of Victorian protestant society
of the 19th Century
discouraged child's play
and emphasized hard work
and applying yourself.
The YMCA and the Christian
Endeavor groups started
promoting something they
called muscular Christianity,
which was encouraging people
to get out and exercise
and develop their bodies
as well as their spirit.
And so this became kind of the
cultural turning point for a lot
of young boys in particular
and Kansas City was one
of the places that
was happening.
And then California in the
1880s was obviously still very
rural place.
There was barely a Los
Angeles at the time.
The center of activity was San
Francisco and the Bay Area,
but every town was, had its own
baseball, amateur baseball team.
And they started developing
a routine what they called
Sunday baseball.
They'd take one day off a week
and 2 towns would challenge
each other and play baseball.
So baseball was really much more
of an amateur sport until 1900s
when the Pacific Coast League
really got off the ground.
Professional baseball never
really did before then.
Frank Chance was one of the
early kids who got involved.
This is a picture of the
Fresno Expositors named
after the newspaper
that sponsored them.
Frank is the 12-year old lying
on the bottom left
on the floor there.
He was the youngest player on
the team and they would, again,
they would go around challenging
kids from other leagues
but the newspaper bought
them these fancy uniforms.
So, these are the 3 young
men as the century turned
from 1890s to the 2000s.
Each bringing with them
kind of their own reason
for getting involved
in baseball,
which was not necessarily
what young men were supposed
to do at the time.
For Tinker I think it
was very much a desire
for middle class acceptance,
acceptability rising
from the kind of lower rungs of
the social order he grew up in.
He saw baseball as a way to
get that kind of acceptance.
Johnny Evers it was,
there was an expression
in south Troy called south
Troy against the world.
And there was a strong
Irish/Catholic sense
of grievance against the
Anglo-Saxon overlords
from England as well as
in the United States.
This was, again, the period
where the No Irish Need Apply
signs were hung on shop walls.
So baseball, the Irish were
incredible baseball players.
In fact, they almost
took over the game.
In the 1890s, there was 4 or
5 Irish players on every team
at the time and I go into the
book a little bit why I think
that is, but part of it
is because they realized
that was one way they could beat
the protestant Anglos they were
up against.
For Chance I think it
was for him a question
of proving himself
worthy of his parents
and grandparent's legacy.
There wasn't a way
to cross the country
like the Oregon Trail was
but sports in particular
and baseball ultimately
became a way for him
and baseball competition to
prove himself on the field.
There was only one problem
at the time the 1890s
professional baseball had turned
really sour.
It was no longer
fun and carefree.
In fact, it was dirty
and mean and vicious.
One woman writer would
later call it the rough
and tumble game played by
9 rowdies for the benefit
of a crowd of hoodlums.
And not surprisingly
not too many women
and children would show
up for these things.
In fact, even the kids
games these were cartoons
from several papers printed
called The Usual Windup,
which is how baseball games
would end up at the time.
So there was essentially 3
reasons baseball was turning
sour in the 1890s,
professional baseball.
I don't know if you've heard
of these words, hoodlumism,
which is essentially the idea of
dirty baseball anyway, cheating,
anything you could do to get a
competitive edge whether it's
spiking your opponent
to, the trick was to,
because there was
only one umpire.
If an umpire was
looking the other way,
you could round a base and miss
third base by 10 or 20 feet
as you were heading home.
Anything you could
do to get away,
but it was also very
foul mouthed,
which is what billingskate
[phonetic] means.
That's essentially cursing,
swearing, vulgarity.
It got so bad that the National
League had to issue an edict
against this kind of language
and they printed a memo,
which I can't read to
you in mixed company,
but I put it in the book.
And just put memo saying these
are the words you cannot say
on the field.
And by penalty of suspension
from the game for life.
Of course no one
would suspend anybody
for life for a curse word.
So it was honored in the breach.
So anyway that was [inaudible].
And then there was this
called syndicate baseball,
which the National League
would try to monopoly
in the 1890s essentially adopted
the practice of the owners
of encouraging each other
to buy minority stakes
in the other's franchises.
And so toward the end of
the season if one team
that you were part
of was winning the
other team was losing,
you'd trade the good players
on the losing team immediately
to the better team and give
yourself a competitive edge.
Sports writer saw through that.
They're the ones who came
up with this term
syndicate baseball,
but some of the fans
I mean attendance
in National League games was
really plummeting particularly
compared to other sports that
were emerging in the gay 90s.
Bicycling, big, huge craze
for bicycling in the 1890s
and bicycle competitions.
Another thing called
pedestrianism.
I don't know if anybody
has heard of that,
but these are walking races
sometimes very absurd walking
races like weeks long
or things like that,
but people would show up,
hundreds and thousands
of people would show
up for these things.
So baseball had a problem and
it was personified by this guy,
John Mugsy McGraw, who
was the third baseman
for the Baltimore Orioles.
He was the one famous for
grabbing the runner's belt
as he rounded third
base and keeping him
from running into home.
In fact, McGraw is,
then he became manager
of the New York Giants
in the 1900s.
And his name McGrawism became
synonymous with dirty baseball
and that's what the sports
writers used to call it.
Fortunately, there was a
visionary out in the Midwest
by the name of Ban Johnson,
Byron Bancroft Johnson.
He was the president
of the Western League,
a minor league at the time.
He saw an opportunity and so he
renamed his league the American
League, moved the headquarters
to Chicago, set up franchises
in Boston and Philadelphia
and New York right
up against the National
League teams,
which had been prohibited
before then with the agreement
that had operated between
the major and minor leagues.
And promoted what he
called clean baseball
that people could not be
afraid to bring their wives
and children to the game, where
the umpires had the rule of law
and he would back them up.
There would be none of the
cheating, cursing and dirty play
that characterized
the National League.
And lo and behold the American
League teams started outdrawing
National League teams
or outdrawing National
League teams.
The White Sox, which had
set up in the Southside
of Chicago was outdrawing
the Colts as they were called
in the National League.
So, essentially Johnson declared
war on the National League
and the National League
sued for peace and they came
up with what's called the
National Agreement of 1903
or the two leagues agreed
to abide by the same rules
of recruiting and payments
and things like that
and then the NL itself had
to respond with its own kind
of discipline, interdiscipline,
and fortunately
in Chicago they found a guy
named Frank Sealey [phonetic]
who had been the manager,
very successful manager
of the Boston Bean
Eaters in the early 1890s
and had brought Sealey in
to manage the Colts in 1902
and he's very cerebral,
soft spoken leader.
He never played baseball
himself unlike McGraw,
but he did manage very
successful teams in the Midwest,
and he also had a secret weapon,
which is his wife, May Sealey.
This is a feature story
from the Chicago Tribune
where they featured
her as the wife
of Chicago's manager
is a real baseball fan.
She was an Irish
immigrant herself,
came over when she was 18.
Very free spirited as I
said rabid baseball fan,
she was a horsewoman
in her own right.
She's also I discovered what
I think is the first female
sports writer.
She went out with the Colts
to California during spring
training in 1903 and got hired
by a couple of newspapers in
Chicago to send back dispatches
of how the team is doing.
These were unsigned, but you
could definitely tell just
from the tone and kind of sunny
disposition she was not the
grizzled sports writers
of the day.
She was sending back signs of
hope for Colts fans to Chicago.
So together the Sealey's
kind of spearheaded a revival
of baseball in Chicago
from 1903 through 1905.
The Colts started
gradually going up,
moving up the standings.
In 1905, it looked like
they might even get close
to winning the pennant but then
Sealey's own health problems
caught up to him and
he became very ill
and was ultimately diagnosed
as tuberculosis and he had
to leave the team
and the city and go
out to Denver to
try to get better.
And so they turned the
team over to Frank Chance
as player/manager on an interim
basis that year and then he took
over in 1906 and 1906
was the big turning point
in Chicago baseball
for two reasons.
One, the Colts now
being called the Cubs,
which is the term
France Chance preferred.
Went on to win 116
games that season.
The Boston Red Sox this year
won 108, which is as much
as anybody has won
in a long time.
One hundred and sixteen
is still a record.
The Seattle Mariners tied
it in 2001 in 162 games.
This was in 153 I think the
Cubs played that year or 152.
So they were a juggernaut,
but across town
down to Southside
the White Sox known
as the hitless wonders back then
because they had an anemic
offense actually won the pennant
on the last day of the season.
And so the two Chicago
teams were going
to meet in the World Series.
First across town
World Series 1906.
During that year,
Chance had gone out
and decided they needed
a new third basemen,
which has become one of
the great trivia questions
in baseball who was the fourth
member of the Cubs infield
and there are two
right answers to this.
One is I don't know.
If anybody knows why
that is the right answer?
That's Abbott and Costello's
third baseman is I don't know.
[Laughter] The other is
Harry Steinfeld was his name.
He's a young man from Ft.
Worth, Texas, where he was
a bicyclist in the 1890s.
He also was, got hooked up with
a black-faced minstrel group
that toured Texas, which is
almost like a circus back then
but he would play baseball
during his off hours
and was discovered
doing that and signed
to a minor league contract
and ended up in Detroit.
Chance had known about him
and decided he wanted him
and so they got him in 1906
and he turned out to be,
this is Steinfeld on the left,
the best hitter on the team
and then the Cubs also had
one of the great pitchers
of all time Mordecai Peter
Centennial Brown was his name
from Nyesville, Indiana.
He had a nickname also 3 Finger
because as a boy when he was
about 5 years old he was
in a farming accident
and his hand got mauled by a
kind of chopper and so he only,
this is what his
pitching hand looked like.
It enabled him to
throw the most bizarre
and unhittable curve ball
you could ever image.
[Laughter] So he and Christian
Matheson were probably the two
greatest pitchers of their era.
Mordecai is in the
Hall of Fame now.
As I said, Chance
became manager.
Here's a picture of
him with Hugh Jennings
of the Detroit Tigers.
As I said, Chance was
a monster in the field.
He probably was the one player
who everyone rallied around.
He was kind of like a
platoon sergeant in the war.
Everyone was willing to
go into battle with him
because he led by example.
Anyway something
happened in Chicago
that summer nearly everyone in
Chicago is crazy about baseball
and this is a picture of
the Westside grand stands
where the Cubs played.
Instead of getting a few
hundred or a few thousand fans
out for an afternoon game,
they were now drawing tens
of thousands to the
games particularly
when the World Series
came around.
In fact, the Tribune
ran a tongue
and cheek column here called
the only man in Chicago
who doesn't know the
Cubs and Sox are fighting
for a world's championship.
[Laughter] He's a
butcher with 3 daughters.
[Laughter] So what happened is
also part of baseball history.
Any Sox fans, White Sox
fans in the audience?
[Laughter] You don't
know them, right?
Cubs as I said had 116 wins that
season, the Sox had 93 or 94
or something like that.
They kind of snuck in
and everyone assumed the
Cubs were just going to roll
over the Sox in the World
Series except for one man,
Hugh Fullerton was the sports
writer for the Chicago Tribune
who sat down and he was kind
of the first sabermetric
writer in his day.
He sort of lined up all the
pros and cons, field conditions,
the weather, the attributes of
each team and wrote a column
that predicted that the
Sox would win the pennant,
the World Series, in 6 games.
Well, would have predicted
that except his editor
wouldn't print the column.
He was afraid everyone in town
would think they were crazy.
And what happened?
Well, the Sox won the
series in 6 games.
The Tribune editor
finally ate crow
and ran the column a week
later after the fact,
but Hugh Fullerton was,
became later known as the man
who sniffed out the
1919 Black Sox scandal.
He was played by Studs
Terkel in the movie Eight Men
Out if you've seen that one.
He didn't look anything
like Studs Terkel.
I didn't bring a picture with me
but he was very urbane
intellectual.
As I said, one of the first
sabermetric sports writers
became one of the great
magazine writers of his day.
But anyway baseball
was back here and back
to such an extent this is
a picture from the Tribune
of the corner of Dearborn and
Madison Streets in Chicago
and all these people are looking
up at the Chicago Tribune
Building that afternoon.
I don't have, they don't
have a picture of what was
on the Tribune Building
that day,
but this is what it was here
in Washington the same thing.
It was an electric
scoreboard in which they would
by telegraph they would
feed every pitch and play
to operators of the scoreboard
and they would use
electric lightbulbs
to signify the runners
who were on base,
the count and every play.
So basically you're following
the game in realtime play
by play from downtown
Chicago to across the country.
These electric scoreboards
became a real thing in this part
of the century before
radio came along in 1920s.
It wasn't until the 1920s
that the radio took that away.
So baseball was I said back.
It was even invading
popular culture.
Back in those days Tin Pan
Alley produced sheet music
because every home had a piano.
Again, no radio, no phonographs,
people played their own music
so it was a big market for
songs, sing-a-long songs
and tunes and things like that.
Baseball was never a topic
of those tunes until now.
This was one of the first.
Cubs on Parade, which was
described as a 2-step march,
but this, I love this picture
and that's Frank Chance
and the Cub's owner Charles
Murphy in the photograph.
So that was 1907 right after
the Cubs won their first
World Series.
In 1908, a guy named Jack
Norworth was looking around
and realized baseball
might be a good topic.
He was not a baseball fan
himself, but he wanted
to write his, a tune
about baseball and he came
up with the lyrics
and signed up a buddy
of his named Albert Bontilsand
[phonetic] to do the music.
This is the verse.
So all these tunes, you
know, before you got
to the course they would
have a verse that was kind
of half sung, half spoken.
Katie Casey was baseball mad.
Had the fever and had it bad.
Just to root for the hometown
crew every sou, Katie blew.
On a Saturday her young
beau called to see if she'd
like to go to see a show,
but Miss Kate said no.
I'll tell you what you can do.
Take me out to the ball game.
So that was the hit piece of
music, sheet music in 1908
and spawned a whole raft of
imitators and things like that.
Dozens of baseball songs started
coming about, which tells you
that this is no longer
just a game for cranks
as they called fans
back in the day
and bugs, but women, children.
In fact, lady's day became
a big thing back then.
At the same time that a
craze swept through fashion,
American fashion based on
operetta that had opened
in London the year
before and now is coming
to New York called
the Merry Widow.
And this was the
star of the show.
I got her name wrong down here,
but this hat became a craze
when the show moved to
New York to the extent
that every woman middle
class and upper class women
in the country wanted
one of these hats
and they were very elaborate.
This is actually a
modest one by comparison.
Some would have fruit, stuffed
birds and things like that.
The brims would be, well,
these women started showing
up to baseball games
and caused quite a stir
for anybody sitting behind
them trying to watch the game.
One sports writer says you can
tell a real lady is the one
who takes off her
hat at the game.
[Laughter] But the Cubs
were now kings of the world.
They had won the World
Series in 1907 and 1908.
Adopted the Cubs
as their nickname.
This is their mascot
at the time.
Not all was sweetness
and light, of course.
In fact, these 2 guys, Joe
Tinker and Johnny Evers,
maintained a feud that they had
started a couple of years before
and refused to talk to
each other on field or off.
You can kind of tell.
They don't really look like they
like each other here
even though they were,
they could wordlessly they were
the best keystone combination
in baseball at the time.
They had a feud that
lasted now just
through their playing
days but even long after.
But baseball was like I
said affecting the culture.
Feature stories were showing
up not just in sports magazines
but in the magazines of
today, which was the Internet
of the day because everyone
had their own magazine.
Players started turning up as
product spokesmen for things
like socks and underwear
and other things
like that not just tobacco.
As I said, Tinker was recruited
to perform in Vaudeville.
In 1909 just after winning
election of the presidency,
William Howard Taft took
a tour across the country,
a 13,000-mile tour by train.
Stopped in Chicago for
a few days and insisted
on taking in a baseball game.
In fact, they rescheduled
the game
for the day he was
available and he showed
up at Westside Grounds, this
is a close up of that picture,
and just held court all day long
and a couple of things happened.
When they showed up, it was
a band kind of roving band
of musicians they immediately
started playing the Star
Spangled Banner when
he showed up,
which was not the National
Anthem at the time.
It was just a popular march
and the whole crowd stood
up at the same time.
And then later on during the
game he decided he wanted
to stretch his legs.
Obviously he's a big
man about 300 pounds
and it was the middle
of the 7th inning.
He stood up and everyone in
the field stood up with him.
It was the first instance I can
find of the 7th inning stretch.
The thing about this the
Cubs I wanted to show this
because this shows their
record for the 10 years
that the 3 players, Tinker,
Evers and Chance played together
in the infield almost unheard of
that 3 players would be together
for 10 years, but each of
these ones highlighted here
on the right the win totals 116
wins in 1 year, 223 in 2 years,
530 in 5 years, 980 in 10
years, it's still a record.
No one, not the Yankees of Babe
Ruth and Lou Gehrig or Mantle
and Marris or Jeter and other.
Not the big red machine,
the Cincinnati Reds,
no team in baseball
history has surpassed any
of these win totals, which makes
you realize one reason they're
in the Hall of Fame all 3.
They were elected
in 1946 together
by a veteran's committee.
Still controversial
in some cases.
A lot of people question if
they have the individual player
statistics that merit Hall
of Fame consideration.
I argue 2 things.
One, I'm not the
only one who argues
that the win totals
justifies their existence
because they were definitely
the leaders of the team,
but what they did for
baseball, what this team did
for baseball at the time.
In fact, a word used most often
to describe the Chicago Cubs
of this era and this is the
Chicago Cubs I'm talking about,
the word most used to describe
the cubs was invincible.
So these 3 young boys,
again, spent the first decade
of the 20th Century
essentially remaking baseball
and they did it through
a work ethic of teamwork,
relentless pursuit
of excellence.
Here's a famous picture
by George Conlin,
he's here in the
Library of Congress.
Obviously these guys did
not want to be pulled
into the dugout and have their
picture taken at the time.
They were in the middle of their
practice, but those are the ones
that turned into these
incredible baseball cards
which we were able to use
for the cover of the book.
But, again, I think by the time
they left the scene baseball
really was the national
pastime and would continue to be
and grow in many different ways
throughout the year, but they,
one of the things I
wanted to do was to kind
of reclaim the origin
story of the Chicago Cubs
because they didn't
quite fit the narrative
of the past 100 years, but I
think they deserve to be now so.
Thank you very much.
I'll be happy to
answer any questions.
[ Applause ]
Anybody have any
questions or comments?
Sir?
[ Inaudible ]
What was the reasons
they didn't win?
Well, strangely the White
Sox started hitting.
They didn't expect that.
The White Sox had a very good
pitching core a couple of Hall
of Famers, and the weather was,
it was a lousy weather
situation.
So there's one reason.
If you go through each game and,
well, White Sox won, Cubs won,
White Sox won, Cubs won
and the White Sox won too.
It was a strange kind of
sequence that no one expected
to happen, but that's what
happens in 7-game series
as every baseball fan knows.
Sometimes the best teams
don't actually come out.
>> So what's the story
about the feud between?
>> David Rapp: The feud
between, I think it was over,
I think I pieced it together.
So, I think it goes back to,
well, I think it goes back
to when Evers first showed
up in 1902 he was brought
down from Troy in September of
1902 in an all-night train ride
and fitted out with a uniform
that was 10 sizes
too big for him.
Went out and had a, it
was a double header,
Labor Day double header,
and had a terrible outing,
but because he was
the rookie the rest
of the team was hazing him.
So they made him, they
used to take these omnibus,
horse-drawn omnibus to the park.
They would dress in the hotel,
take an omnibus to the park
and when he came out
to get on the bus,
they said there's no room on
the bus you have to sit on top.
So he had to sit on
top out to the park
and he had a terrible day and
he had to sit back on the top
on the way back and
he knew all the guys
down below were making
fun of him.
Well, one of those
guys was the one
who was the rookie before
showed up, Joe Tinker.
And so by a couple years
later most of the other people
on that team had been reshuffled
and Sealey had brought
in all kinds of other people,
but Tinker was still there
and then in 1905 the Cubs were
on their way to Cincinnati
by train and stopped
off in Bedford, Indiana,
for an exhibition game with
the local minor league team
because one of their
pitchers was from Bedford.
And the town pulled
out all the stops
and actually had 5 handsome
cabs for all the players,
to take all the players to
the ball park and the last,
both Tinker and Evers were
kind of late getting dressed
and Evers came down first and
saw the last cab there hopped on
and said take me to the
ball park and left Tinker
to walk the mile on the hot
dusty road to the ball park.
So they were warming
up before the game
and Tinker took the ball and
about the distance from me
to you threw it as hard as he
could at Evers and Evers used
to show his hand how mangled
it was because of that.
Within a few seconds they
were on the ground brawling.
Well, the pitcher, I forgot his
name, for Bedford, turns around
and sees his teammates and runs
over and tries to break them up
and they kind of pull
him down into the melee.
So the 3000 fans and the fans
see their local hometown hero
getting beat up and they
all rushed to the scene.
[Laughter] Order is
restored after all of this,
they play the game as
if nothing had happened,
the fight gets mentioned
in the newspapers all
over the country,
but not the reason.
It was Hugh Fullerton
again a year later
who described this cab incident
as the cause which started it,
but and I think that actually
goes back because the Irish,
you know, have long memories,
you know, never forgive,
never forget, and it
was almost 3 years
that Evers was finally able
to get his revenge on Tinker
with that cab incident, but
they basically had said, look,
you know, we can't play
together if we're going to talk
to each other so we just
won't talk to each other.
Oddly Tinker said they were
the first to defend the other
in any fight against another
player on another team.
It says we're Cubs first,
individuals second, you know,
they had the team
ethic [inaudible].
And, in fact, it was Chance who
probably kept them, you know,
because when Chance was hurt
at the end of the 1912 season
and had to leave the team, they
named Evers interim manager,
which was the last thing Tinker
wanted and there were a couple
of fights in the dugout
that players had to break
up the 2 guys and Tinker
finally left and jumped leagues
to the new Federal League
to get away from Evers.
They reconciled back in the
1930s, but it was a long time.
[ Inaudible ]
Okay, so Chance was the first
one who had to leave in 1912.
He had brain surgery.
Another thing about
him being touch
as a corn husk he never
dodged a bullet or a baseball
and it was actually this side.
He got hit in the head a
lot of times to the extent
that he lost his hearing
and so he had left.
He actually came back a year or
so later and managed the Yankees
or the Highlanders they
were called at the time.
It was before Babe
Ruth joined the team
so they were a lousy team
and they didn't do much.
He ended up in, back
in California
and helped really get the
Pacific Coast League going
as vice president and management
of the teams and he died young.
He was in his 50
years old or something
like that when he died.
Tinker as I said jumped leagues
to the new Federal League,
which the Chicago
Whales [phonetic] played
in a new park called Weeghman
Park on the Northside,
which Weeghman as the owner
of the league of the Whales,
the league only lasted a year
but Weeghman then bought
the Cubs and moved them
up to Weeghman Park and then
he eventually sold the park
and the team to Wrigley,
William Wrigley
and it's been Wrigley
Field ever since.
And so he played rough
and Tinker jumped
around for a few years, managed
some, never successfully,
and he ended up in Florida
as a real estate speculator
during the Florida real estate
boom and won and lost and won
and lost a fortune a
couple of times there.
Johnny Evers had an
interesting kind of second act.
He got sold to the
Boston Braves in 1914
and was given a $40,000 salary.
The highest paid player
in baseball at the time.
The Boston Braves were
in last place in August.
Evers was the captain of the
team and they're now known
as the Miracle Braves
because they ended
up winning the pennant and
the World Series that year.
Definitely behind Johnny.
He ended up going
back and managed
for the Cubs a bit,
for the White Sox.
He jumped around and ended up
living out his days in Troy,
New York, as owner
of a shoe store.
That's his things.
Sir?
[ Inaudible ]
No, never.
Yeah. They're not known as
a double play combination.
That's the odd thing,
but one reason is
because very few
runners got to first
against their pitching core.
They didn't have that many
opportunities for double plays,
but yeah that one
that [inaudible] is one
Franklin Adams picked up on
and made a thing, yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Frank Chance is the best
player of the 3 definitely.
Johnny Evers I think was,
again, showing what he did
in Boston I think proved it
that he was probably the best
on-field captain any team could
have, but Tinker, Tinker
was probably the hardest one
to justify based
on his statistics.
Although I do want to point
out that Christian
Matheson [phonetic],
again the best pitcher
of his day along
with three-fingered
Brown, on the first page
of his autobiography, first
page said I could never get Joe
Tinker out.
He had to get that out
of the way right away.
Tinker hit like 400
against Christian Matheson.
He was one of the
clutch hitters especially
in that 1907-1908 seasons
they won the World Series.
[ Inaudible ]
So, yeah. So the, I didn't get
into that so I'm glad you asked.
So the Cubs had won the pennant
in 1906, dethroning the Giants
who had been the world champions
from 1905 and McGraw's Giants,
they lost the World Series,
in 1907 they came back
with a vengeance and won the
pennant and the World Series
against the Detroit
Tigers in 4 games.
I think one was a
rain out so 5 games,
but and then 1908 there was
a pennant race of all time
and it was actually a
great book about just
that one season called Crazy
08 if anybody is interested,
but it's the Giants, the
Cubs and the Pirates,
Honus Wagner's Pirates, were
in a pennant race until,
the 3 of them until literally
the last day of the season.
There was one game in
particular it's famous
for what's been known as one of
the great baseball [inaudible]
of all time Merkle's Boner.
A young kid named Fred Merkle
was on first base in the bottom
of the ninth inning with a
runner on third base as well
and the Giants hit a single
up the middle, clean single
into center field that scored
the run from third base
to win the game and 2
weeks before the end
of the season everyone thought
would be propel the Giants
to the pennant.
But Johnny Evers who had been
studying the rule book as I said
at night in bed had tried,
the habit was at the time
if something like that
happened the runner
at first base wouldn't go
to second, touch second,
he would just run to the
dugout or in that case
into the outfield club house
and that's what Merkle did.
It was a big game,
thousands of fans,
he sees the winning run score
and the fans start pouring
onto the field, his Giants
teammates are running
out of the dugout toward
the right field club house
to get away from the fans
so Merkle just turned
around halfway between
first and second
and hightailed it with them.
Johnny Evers saw this, called
for the ball from center field,
the ball comes flying in misses
him completely and hits Tinker
in the back and falls into
the middle of the infield.
Well, the fans are streaming
on him and the first base coach
of the Giants, Joe McGinnity
was one of the great pitchers
but this day was coaching first
base sees all this happening
and kind of sizes up what Evers
is up to and runs on the field
and grabs the ball and tries
to throw it into the stands,
but Joe Tinker has got
a bear hug around him
so he can't throw it
very far and it lands
over by the Cubs dugout
where there's also a bag
of balls and things like that.
Everyone races to that
ball, a fan picks it up
and holds it aloft and one of
the Cubs pitchers says give me
that ball and he said no.
So he just bopped him over
the head and the ball dropped
and he grabbed it and threw it
back to Evers who was standing
on second base at this time and
there was actually 2 umpires
for this game not
necessarily a usual thing,
but one of them had been, Hank
O'Day was the home plate umpire,
had seen the same play,
Evers pulled the same play 2
weeks before in Pittsburgh.
Oh, he didn't see it.
That was what Hank O'Day claimed
he didn't see the ball being
tagged before the runner got
there so he disallowed it
but the Cubs put up such a stink
about it and protested the game
that Evers, O'Day finally said,
well, you're probably right.
If it happens again,
I'd call him out.
So, 2 weeks later in New
York it happened again
but here's the thing New
York fans have complained
about this forever because
it was the custom not
to touch second base, it's a
technicality, it's a force out,
the run doesn't score.
Well, O'Day admitted
and I found a piece,
an interview he gave
to the Tribune.
He hardly ever talked
about this thing,
but he actually managed the Cubs
in 1914 I think it was a year
after Evers and he's still
living in Evers' shadow
and never liked him as you
can imagine no umpire would
like Johnny Evers.
So he was giving and
he was basically trying
to downplay Evers' role in
the Merkle's Boner play.
It wasn't Evers he says
it was Sully Hoffman
out in center field who
recognized what was happening
and threw the ball in,
but then he said, well,
and besides it didn't matter.
He says I called it interference
because McKinney ran
onto the field before
the play was over
and that's what he ruled and,
therefore, the play was dead,
And it was the bottom of
the 9th and it was darkness
so they called the game
because of darkness.
And any Cubs fans, older
Cub's fans like me remember
if you call a game because
of darkness in Chicago,
the Cubs didn't have
lights until 1988,
you have to replay
the entire game.
You don't just pick it
up where it left off.
So the National League
finally ruled
that the game was suspended
because of darkness is a tie
and would be replayed at the
end of the season if necessary
and it was necessary just like
these last, this last week
and the Cubs won that game
pretty easily although there
was, they figured it was
in the [inaudible] Grounds
250,000 people showed up for
that game both in the park, on
the roof of the stadium but also
on Cogan's Bluff overlooking
the stadium it was one
of the biggest gatherings of
humanity in history up until
that point, but that's what
decided the 1908 season was
that one play.
I think one more question?
[ Inaudible ]
I can't, I should know that but
I can't, but none of them were
over 300 for instance.
I would say I think Chance ended
up, well, I did look this up.
If you look at Chance's numbers
from the 5 years they won
in 1906, his on-base percentage
which is what everyone
looks at today, right?
So it's hits, walks
and hit by pitches.
Frank Chance was hit 90
times during those 5 years.
[Laughter] Which pushes his
on-base average up to 480
or something like that.
So that was him but the
other 2 were more like 260,
280 hitters essentially
in that range, yeah.
One more.
[ Inaudible ]
It was a sports writer.
So back in those days team
didn't necessarily own
their nicknames.
It was not like today where
they're brand trademarks.
The sports writers gave
them nicknames and there's
so many newspapers that
each paper used to come
up with its own nickname for the
team just to distinguish itself.
So, the White Stockings,
which is what the original
National League franchise was
called, kind of lost
that moniker
when they were rebuilding
under Cap Ansen in the 1890s
and reporters started calling
them the Colts, Ansen's Colts
because they were all young
kids he had gathered together,
but then when Ansen left he
was kind of the patriarch
of Chicago baseball
and he played
until he was 48 years old one
paper started calling them
the Orphans.
And then they started writing
some other minor league teams
and one paper called
them the Remnants.
But Sealey came in and he liked
Colts so he encouraged that,
but 1906 one paper called
them the Giant Killers.
That was the nickname
the whole season long,
but again when Sealey
started bringing in a bunch
of young kids, this is what he
was he was a great talent scout,
including kids like Evers and
Tinker 20 years old at the time,
one sports writer from the Daily
News said it looked like a bunch
of cubbies on the field and
that was essentially the start
of that craze and then Chance
made it known that he liked it
and then Murphy, Charles
Murphy I didn't get
into the new owner was a big
promoter type and he's the one
that came up with the mascot of
the bear and things like that.
So and then I think the end of
the story is the football team,
NFL football team, which emerged
in the 30s and 40s, wanted to,
and they played in
Wrigley Field,
couldn't use the word Cubs,
but they latched on to Bears.
I think that's the story.
I'll be happy to stick around
and answer any other questions,
but I think we have to, and
then I'll be happy to sign books
that are for sale right
out here in the lobby
if anyone would like, but thank
you all very much for coming.
[ Applause ]